[Musique]
qui nous lâche pas son faut une affaire
personnelle
romane on est là pour faire diversion
rien de plus tu as tout péter en route
tu espérais quoi je suis roumanie reçoit
merde
ces matchs base de phase 2 c'est quoi la
phase 2 de la peau
non tout
tu sais ce que j'aime chez toi comme tu
as un vrai hors la loi mais ta famille
joli travail mon frère une fois la base
je paye ma tournée elle va devoir
affronter le seul truc qu'elle ne peut
pas vaincre toi
tu aurais imaginé traire ta famille
comme tu l'as fait aujourd'hui dominique
parent et or s'est retourné contre nous
retient tiens regarde et qui est là je
sais pas pourquoi il a fait mais ça peut
pas être demain
elle est l'incarnation même du
terrorisme high tech et maintenant elle
collabore avec votre homme
je crois que j'ai trouvé mon équipe
ça ça m'intéresse
elle voulait jouer ça
ou c'est impossible c'est pourquoi il
vous faudra un petit coup de main je
vais te mettre l'apprend l'état vie
ça a pris plus de temps que je le
pensais si vous voulez choper d'hommes
tous allaient devoir bosser ensemble
surprise suis raide dingue
depuis le temps que j'en rêve on attend
qu en réseau
et niveau là c'est pas si dame le bret
est dans le coin je m'en tape
je vais peut-être minable torito on va
s'amuser pourquoi il va le blues
je sais pas peut-être parce que tel lot
more ligne orange monsieur patel
[Musique]
tiens
ce fiasco
il nous faudrait un plus grand camion
non tu coures vraiment lâché ta famille
[Musique]
on va s'amuser